a California lawmaker accused of child
cruelty is speaking out saying he
intended to discipline his
seven-year-old daughter with a spanking
State Assemblyman Joaquin arambula is
home with his three children this
morning the children were briefly
removed by Child Protective Services
Jericka Duncan is here with the case
highlighting the legal risk of corporal
punishment even for parents tarika
duncan good morning to you good morning
this Isis story happening on which way
you fall on the spectrum well it's
important to point out that spanking
your child is legal in all 50 states but
if it crosses the line into cruelty or
abuse it becomes a crime with
potentially harsh punishments for the
parent involved luckily Ram Beulah was
sworn in at California State Assemblyman
two years ago his wife and three young
daughters were at his side a Randle ax
was arrested earlier this week he says
he spanked his eldest child who told her
teacher the next morning we have nights
where we can get overwhelmed that night
was a night that she was acting out
school administrators called Child
Protective Services after allegedly
noticing an injury on the girls body she
was really angry that he spanked her and
she woke up angry and she went to school
angry and wanted to be heard a Randle ax
was arrested on suspicion of willful
cruelty to a child a misdemeanor he says
he spanked his daughter on the buttocks
but the police chief says other evidence
led to a rambilas arrest injury in this
case is not on the buttocks police plan
to send the case to the district
attorney next week a rambilas attorney
did not respond to our request for
comment but in a statement to the Fresno
Bee they said it is disappointing that
chief Dyer has taken to the media in
order to try this case in the court of
public opinion we have offered to meet
with the representatives of the district
attorney's office so that relevant
information can be presented a ram
Beulah a board-certified physician
maintains his innocence I'm a healer by
nature I'm a doctor and it's not in my
nature to actually be assertive and
aggressive
like that while spanking is legal the
courts consider it excessive if it
leaves physical injuries family law
specialist Donald Schweitzer in my
practice
I tend to tell my clients don't use
corporal punishment because you never
know who's going to determine that is
reasonable or unreasonable a regulars
attorneys say the children were returned
to their parents two days after the
father's arrest after child welfare
services determined there were no
concerns about abuse if convicted a ram
below could face a year in jail and like
you said jerrika this is really a
controversial issue because so much
depends on how people were raised right
and what they saw in their own home as
my mom used to say you're a different
child than your sisters your mom do you
spank yourself now do i spank myself no
ok good jury kid Duncan got jokes
you spanked your door I'm big on timeout
you again but every once in a while
there's a threat yes and I tried not to
I really you know she's five years old
and I like it and especially if you
leave marks on your child yeah
absolutely but I know it's a personal
decision and it's legal everybody has to
make their own decision by it I just
don't think it helps which I don't
Yvonne Duncan is an excellent and your
daughter has joke
[Laughter]